[Musique]
merci lcent deay de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élon avoir invité elud de lesson
membre du groupe Union centriste et
rapporteur de cette commission d'enquête
qui a été lancé hier sur la question des
prix de l'électricité de la production
d'électricité on va en parler dans
quelques instants mais
d'abord l'actualité politique 2 semaines
quasiment après sa nomination Gabriel
LAL n'a toujours pas fait son discours
de politique générale il est prévu dans
10 jours est-ce que c'est trop tard pour
vous non moi je pense que prendre son
temps à la fois pour former un
gouvernement et puis pour aussi
réfléchir à la politique générale que
l'on va mener ça me paraît pas non plus
excessif voilà il faut arrêter de
vouloir aller toujours trop vite donc
moi je suis pas je pense qu'il faut il
faut prendre son temps il faut bien
réfléchir et ensuite il faut agir et
c'est ce qu'on attend du gouvernement et
du président de la République c'est des
actions il a réussi ses premier pas de
Premier ministre Gabriel hatal pour vous
bah écoutez en tout cas il il présente
bien il parle bien donc ça c'est c'est
c'est quelque chose qui qui plaît il il
sa'est faire de ce point de vuelà après
euh il sera jugé à ses actes comme comme
tout homme politique et donc de ce point
de vue-là je pense que pour l'instant ça
a été il est passé beaucoup trop vite
sur des postes euh importants les
comptes publics ensuite l'éducation pour
moi il a pas eu le temps de faire ses
preuves donc on va voir en tant que
Premier ministre combien de temps il va
rester c'est euh c'est une charge très
difficile le poste de Premier ministre
donc on est on est sur le devant de la
scène en permanence donc voilà moi je je
souhaite qu'il réussisse hein bien sûr
pour la France et puis on souhaite tous
qu'un gouvernement réussisse on a on a
intérêt maintenant voilà il part avec
une situation qui est quand même pas
évidente et donc je je demande à voir
qu'est-ce que vous attendez de son
discours de politique général ce sera le
30 janvier dans une dizaine de jours Ben
qui qui nous donne les grandes priorités
du gouvernement euh les grandes
priorités c'est pas 15 priorités hein
quand quand vous avez 4 C priorités pour
moi c'est le maximum sinon c'est plus
des priorités qu moi je me plains
souvent qu'on a on a l'impression qu'il
y a 30 priorités en France donc ça ça
peut pas il faut se concentrer et pour
ma part moi je suis vous savez très
attaché aux finances publiques et au
sérieux et à la rigueur dans dans la
gestion de l'argent public et donc
j'attends de sa part des engagements sur
ce plan-là euh parce que on va peut-être
y venir mais sur sur la conférence de
presse du Président de la République qui
a annoncé pas mal de mesures
euh des mesures qui vont plutôt prises
individuellement dans le bon sens je
sais pas si ça répond complètement à
l'attente des Français mais enfin bon
après je pense qu'il y a un petit
problème de de diagnostique sur l'état
de la la société française aujourd'hui
entre le président et les Français je
suis pas sûr que ils aient exactement la
même vision de Manuel Macron il décrit
une France tropidyque selon vous un
petit peu un petit peu optimiste mais
c'est un petit peu son rôle aussi mais
les Français ont peut-être une vision un
peu trop pessimiste he parce que quand
on voyage un peu et qu'on voit ce qui ce
qui se passe ailleurs on peut dire qu'on
est pas forcément super malheureux ça
veut pas dire qu'il y a pas des
malheureux en France mais en moyen c'est
quo c'est c'est c'est son rôle d'essayer
d'impulser un petit peu de positif ou ou
c'est la preuve qu'il est déconnecté des
réalités des Français c'est pas facile
le diagnostic est pas facile à faire je
pense que c'est son rôle de de pousser
pour qu'il a de l'optimisme qu' a de
l'envie de dans de faire et d'innover de
d'avancer mais en même temps il faut
quand même se rendre compte aussi a de
la réalité de la vie d'un certain nombre
de Français des contraintes que l'on a
de la façon dont on gère notre pays
parce que en fait on gère notre pays
avec des déficits et late c'est c'estz
simple et c'est ce que je voulais vous
dire par rapport à toutes les mesures
qui ont été annoncées moi j'aiété
surpris que à la fin on disent pas mais
combien ça coûte tout ça personne n'a
posé la question de combien ça coûte qui
va payer et c'est quand même une
question de base quand vous annoncez des
choses vous dites ben voilà c'est le
consommateur c'est on va venir sur
l'électricité c'est le contribuable
là on veut baisser les impôts on veut
faire des tas de mesures nouvelles et
alors qu'on est déjà en super déficit on
a on a 35 % de déficite il faut savoir
c'est pas 3 4 % comme on nous raconte
c'est mais le maire il alerte là-dessus
il dit qu'il va falloir faire des
efforts qu'il va falloir faire des il
est assez mal placé pour alerter parce
que c'est lui qui a dépensé pendant
c'est il a géré quoi qu'il en coûte
c'était des centaines de milliards
par-ci par là et veux-tu en voilà
aujourd'hui il nous dit il faut faire
attention faut arrêter mais ça fait un
petit moment qu'il FA il faut faire ça
et euh ça veut dire que les 2 milliards
de baisse d'impôts pour les classes
moyennes pour vous il faut pas les faire
ben écoutez moi je je suis je
naturellement et par conviction je suis
je pense qu'on a un pays qui est qui est
qui paye trop d'impôts globalement trop
d'impôts et de charge donc il faut
alléger tout ça mais pour alléger tout
ça il faut alléger la dépense publique
si on nallège pas la dépense publique il
y a pas il y a pas de secret qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on reporte tout cet argent
sur vous sur les jeunes générations sur
nos enfants moi je suis effaré des
déficit et des dettes qu'on va on va
laisser en héritage je je je suis
quelqu'un de responsable j'ai toujours
géré l'argent public de façon rigoureuse
et ça ne m'a jamais valu de l'eau prob
ou autre en tout cas j'ai j'ai pu gérer
rigoureusement et pour moi la rigueur
c'est pas c'est quelque chose
d'indispensable quand on gère de
l'argent public et j'ai pas l'impression
que ça soit quand même quelque chose qui
soit largement partagé en France et je
trouve ça dommage un dernier mot
puisquon a vu dans le journal ces images
d'Emmanuel Macron et de Rachid adati
côte à côte hier c'était le premier des
placement politique d'Emmanuel Macron
après le remanement il a choisi de le
faire avec Rachid adati qu'est-ce que
vous pensez vous de cette nomination et
de ce choix écoutez c'est vrai
qu'Emmanuel Macron il l'a dit d'ailleurs
il a toujours essayé de rassembler assez
le plus largement ce qui est bien en soi
et quand on rassemble on rassemble
forcément des gens différents donc moi
je trouve qu'un gouvernement qui veut
rassembler il faut qu'il y ait des
personnalités différentes dedans alors
on pense qu'on veut de Rachid hadti mais
je pense que c'est un coup politique qui
est pas pas forcément mauvais si on
prend sur ce de ce point de vue là et en
même temps c'est quelqu'un qui a
d'expérience qui qui a déjà été ministre
qui peut apporter des des choses alors
elle est sur un secteur la culture qui
qui est pas forcément très facile à à
gérer non plus mais enfin bon en même
temps je elle a dû savoir faire et je
pense qu'elle va réussir à à faire
avancer le sujet de façon positive
est-ce que vous souhaitez parce qu'il y
a une deuxième vague de nomination qui
est attendue est-ce que vous souhaitez
que le
rassemblement déjà oui ou non non non
non mais est-ce que vous souhaitez que
ça aille jusqu'à l'UDI ben écoutez ça
pourrait ça pourrait aller jusqu'à l'UDI
sauf que on sent pas forcément de
volonté de de le faire aujourd'hui euh
en tout cas il faudrait qu'on le fasse
vous vous iriez si on vous le propose
que ça ça dépendrait du discours de
politique générale dont on parlait tout
à l'heure il faut savoir où on va
comment on y va moi si c'est pour y
aller pour pour faire ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à présent c'est du quoi qu'il en
coûte personnellement c'est pas possible
on va justement parler de la hausse des
prix hausse des prix de l'électricité
Emmanuel Macron était également attendu
sur ce sujet mardi puisque c'est un
sujet d'inquiétude pour les Français une
hausse qui est attendue de 10 % au mois
de février on va faire le point sur tout
ça avec Quentin calm qui nous
[Musique]
rejoint Quentin bonjour bonjour Vinc
bonjour et Quentin les de l'électricité
devrait donc augmenter le 1er février
prochain Bruno Le Maire a commencé à
préparer les esprits ça fait plusieurs
mois déjà oui c'est vrai on attend le
décret il doit être pris avant le 31
janvier pour savoir combien à combien va
se chiffrer la hausse du prixt de
l'électricité pour rappel la facture
c'est déjà envolé en 2023 + 15 % en
février de l'année dernière plus 10 % en
août dernier la hausse des tarifs en
2023 représente 430 € selon
l'association l'UFC Que Choisir quand on
prend un consommateur de référence et
donc vous le disiez Orian le prix
devrait continuer à grimper en février
prochain de quoi s'inquiéter écoutterz
le ministre de l'Économie lundi dernier
lors de la visite de la centrale
nucléaire de Graveline dans le Nord
s'agissant de la facture d'électricité
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation de plus
de 10 % comme je m'y suis toujours
engagé 10 % ce serait donc le maximum
acté dans les prochains jours mais cela
pourrait représenter quand même 200 €
supplémentaires cette année sur la
facture moyenne des Français une hausse
du prix d à la hausse des taxes car les
cours de l'électricité sont revenus à la
normale la hausse des prix vous voyez
dans cet article c'est donc bien la
seule responsabilité du gouvernement
c'est ce que dit he ce papier de Public
Sénat les oppositions appellent donc le
gouvernement à revenir sur cette
décision écoutter sur notre antenne
manuel bonpart pour la France insoumise
qui adresse au passage un message à
Gabriel àal cette augmentation de 10 %
du prix de l'électricité au 1er février
est uniquement du à une décision gouvern
gouvernementale le prix de l'électricité
sur les marchés a baissé il y a la
possibilité d'annuler cette hausse il
suffit d'une simple décision
gouvernementale par exemple il pourrait
effectivement décider de le faire
certains observateurs ont même pensé que
le chef de l'État et bien il aurait pu
et bien revenir sur cette hausse lors de
sa grande conférence de presse tous les
regards qui se tournaient vers lui cette
semaine mais donc on attendra de voir ce
que va faire Gabriel Atal le 30 janvier
lors de son discours de politique
générale Emmanuel Macron lors de sa
conférence de presse n'est pas rentré
dans les détails expliquant ne pas
vouloir je cite se substituer au
gouvernement qui doit prendre donc cette
décision écoutez la suite l'électricité
le prix va revenir dans la norme mais
surtout il restera quel que soit ce que
le gouvernement annonce dans les
prochains
jours substantiellement inférieur à ce
qui est payé en Allemagne en Espagne en
Italie ça faut le regarder aussi et donc
là où ça aurait dû augmenter de plus de
100 % l'année dernière ça a dû augmenter
de 25 % l'électricité et on va continuer
d'avoir un prix de l'électricité
nettement inférieur à nos voisins
Vincent delay qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez que doit faire le gouvernement
taxer ou ne pas taxer telle est la
question alors en fait euh le le
gouvernement avait décidé l'an dernier
euh d'aider euh largement les Français
en diminuant les taxes sur l'électricité
de façon à limiter la hausse qui aurait
d être celle du du prix de l'électricité
l'an dernier ça a été limité même si ça
même si on l'a senti quand même hein et
tout le monde l'a senti mais euh donc
aujourd'hui avec euh le prix des marché
qui ont diminué considérablement il
s'était envolé de de façon incroyable
aujourd'hui c'est pas anormal de
d'essayer de retrouver un niveau alors
j'allais dire normal de de taxes après
qu quel est le niveau normal de taxes ça
fait partie des sujets qu'on va aborder
lors de notre commission d'enquête he
c'est c'est c'est aussi c'est aussi sur
cette question du prix moi qui m'a qui
m'a alerté pourquoi on a créé j'ai
souhaité créer cette commission
d'enquête c'est parce que la volatilité
des prix de l'électricité alors que
c'est un produit de première nécessité
hein pour nos pour chacun d'entre nous
pour les entreprises pour la
compétitivité du pays et moi j'ai je me
suis dit c'est pas possible qu'on ait un
système qui soit aussi compliqué avec un
tarif réglementé un marché de gros un
marché spot des des contraintes
européennes personne n'y comprend rien
en fait comment estce pardon oui comment
est-ce qu'il faut comprendre la hausse
de de 10 % que veut le gouvernement
c'est c'est pour renflouer la date du
pays non c'est pour revenir à la normale
je dirais par rapport à la situation
antérieure puisqueen fait on a baissé
considérablement les pratiquement au
minimum he on pour on a étalé en fait la
Haus qu'on aur d
avoirtale dans le temps on l'étale dans
le temps et on rattrape en fait la
hausse de l' dernière pas complètement
pas complètement mais on en rattrape une
partie et euh après est-ce que il faut
continuer comme ça moi je je pense que
on pourra faire des propositions nous en
tout cas au niveau de la commission
d'enquête sur la façon dont on peut
aider ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
c'estàdire ceux qui ont le moins de
moyens de façon ciblé parce que moi je
suis pour des aides ciblées quand on
aide on aide de façon ciblée pas de
façon générale et ensuite comment on
arrive arrive à avoir une électricité
qui aujourd'hui est relativement
compétitive par rapport à l'Europe
peut-être pas par rapport à l'ensemble
du monde hein si on regarde dans le
monde parce qu'on fait toujours des
comparaison avec l'Europe et souvent
l'Europe est plus cher que les
États-Unis que que la Chine et
qu'ailleurs mais et pour notre
compétitivité économique pour nos
entreprises c'est important aussi de
pouvoir avoir une électricité qui soit
compétitive sur les marché vous vous
demandez pas Emmanuel Macron de revenir
sur cette ou au moins de l'amoindrir non
non écoutez je pense que après après il
faut faut qu'on arrive à faire de la
clarté sur le sujet tant qu'on a pas
fait de la clarté sur le sujet moi je
peux pas me prononcer je considère qu'on
a fait que le gouvernement a pris une
décision l'an dernier qu'on pouvait
approuver ou ne pas approuver mais de
faire un gros effort et de demander à
EDF de faire des gros efforts parce que
EDF a fait des pertes considérables
parce que EDF a payé une partie des
décisions prise par le gouvernement les
boucliers oui voilà le bouclier
tarifaire ça ça ça a joué donc
aujourd'hui bon ça va dans l'autre sens
euh je je dirais pas que c'est un
scandale on avait vu que le Sénat avait
essayé de faire un un quelque chose de
de plus ciblé lors du l'examen du budget
à l'automne dernier avec un chèque
électricité pour les 6 dciles les 60 %
de Français classe moyenne classe
modeste le gouvernement avait écarté ce
dispositif à l'automne dernier vous le
regrettez ça aurait été plus malin ben
moi je pense je pense que tout ce qui
est ciblé est plus malin c'est comme les
les 30 centimes de de ristour sur le le
prix de l'essence le carburant c'est
quelque chose qui a bénéficié aux gens
qui partent en weekend en
44 les étrangers qui qui traversent la
France en fait on on a on a payé un peu
tout le monde alors que nous on avait
demandé ici au Sénat que ça soit cibler
et à travers les entreprises on pouvait
cibler sur les gens qui travaillent qui
ont besoin d'utiliser leur voiture pour
travailler donc d'une façon générale
souvent on part trop vite sur des aides
qui sont absolument pas ciblé et qui
coûtent très très cher et qui coûtent
très très cher non pas à nous mais aux
générations futur donc à vous hein par
que vous êtes beaucoup plus jeune que
moi donc c'est vous qui allez qui allez
payer tout ça à la fin parce que on va
on va vous laisser des tonnes de déficit
et de dett mais si on avait suivi les
propositions du Sénat ça veut dire que
la hausse pour certains ménages les plus
aisés c'était votre proposition aurait
été bien au-delà de 10 %. Ah ben c'est
si on avait aidé effectivement de façon
ciblée ben forcément pour des ménages
qui ont des moyens la hausse ils
auraient suivi forcément les contraintes
du marché marché qui est qui est un peu
bizarre he parce que en fait
l'électricité est liée au gaz donc c'est
les prix du gaz qui ont explosé sur les
marchés suite au notamment au conflit en
Ukraine mais il y avait d'autres raisons
aussi et en fait on prend le coût
marginal de production et le coût
marginal de production ça veut dire que
c'est les dernières centrales qu'on
utilise et les dernières centrales la
plupart du temps c'est du gaz donc c'est
pour ça que en fait le le le le prix de
l'électricité est monté aussi aussi haut
aussi vite et notre souci nous à la
commission d'enquête c'est d'essayer de
voir comment on peut rapprocher le prix
euh sur la facture du coût de production
ce qui serait normal c'estàdire que le
coût de production puisse servir de base
au prix de l'électricité Quentin j'ai
une dernière question c'est c'est pas
contreintuitif de vouloir taxer
davantage l'électricité quand on sait
qu'on mise sur cette électricité pour
les voitures pour les mobilités ça va
pas donner un mauvais signal au grand
public alors on ne veut pas taxer
davantage on veut revenir à ce qui était
auparavant et c'est c'est en tout cas
c'est la volonté du gouvernement euh
c'est c'est moi je moi je défends pas
forcément les taxes je dis simplement il
faut remettre tout à plat pour bien
comprendre le système on fera sans doute
des propositions sur sur la partie taxe
hein moi j'ai quelques idées là-dessus
mais je préfère les garder pour
l'instant et pouvoir les partager avec
les membres de la commission et ensuite
voir ce que ce que décide la commission
mais on aura des propositions à faire je
pense que c'est un travail très utile
pour les Français hein qu'on va réaliser
ici au Sénat c'est pas la première fois
qu'on réalise ce type de travail je que
pour comprendre comment fonctionne le
mécanisme du prix voilà du prix et puis
et puis savoir comment on va faire face
parce que on nous dit demain tout va
êtreès électrique tous les usages vont
être électrique donc on on veut
effectivement réduire la place des
énergies fossiles ce qui est normal au
profit de l'électricité mais est-ce
qu'on va être en capacité de produire ou
est-ce que demain on va vous dire bah la
voiture électrique que vous venez
d'acheter là ça sera 2 heur par jour
mais pas plus monsieur donc ça il faut
quand même qu'on puisse le dire aux
Français leur dire est-ce qu'il y aura
des contraintes est-ce qu'il y aura pas
de contraintes alors dans cette
commission d'enquête il y a la question
du prix vous nous l'avez dit vous voulez
faire la transparence il aussi la
question de la production don vous allez
parler voà tout à fait puisque le
président de la République a annoncé à
Belfort en en février 2022 ça fait
quasiment maintenant 2 ans que il
changeit de pied sur le nucléaire on a
laissé le nucléaire en jacher pendant
pas mal d'années et alors que c'était
une industrie que sur laquelle on avait
on était en pointe et on avait beaucoup
d'avance on en a perdu beaucoup il faut
tout reconstituer est-ce que l'on va
assez vite dans cette reconstitution et
comment on va financer tout cela parce
que on dit on va avoir un mix nucléaire
énergie renouvelable combien ça va
coûter combien ça va coûter au mgaw
puisque on voulait rapprocher prix
d'électricité du coût de production donc
il faut qu'on sache comment combien ça
va coûter et comment ça ça va être
financé parce que aujourd'hui si vous
pouvez me le dire vous êtes très forte
la la commission d'enquête vous êtes
réunie hier le bureau s'est constitué
hier est-ce que vous savez déjà quand
vont commencer vos travaux et quelles
seront les premières auditions alors
j'allais dire que mes travaux en tant
que rapporteur ont déjà commencé puisque
moi ça fait un petit moment que je je je
lis pas mal de choses sur le sujet et
j'essaie d'être bien informé et de bien
cibler nos auditions pour qu'elles soi
utiles et euh le travail commence
commence dès la semaine prochaine dès
lundi pr prièition pr les premières
éditions je pense que ça sera dans 10
jours mais avant la fin du mois vous
souhaitez commencer par qui plutôt par
des économistes des universitaires des
techniciens parce queil faut quand même
qu'on on absorbe pas mal d'information
pour pouvoir ensuite aller vers les
décideurs à la fois les les présidents
de grandes entreprises comme EDF bien
sûr total energy ang mais aussi les
ministres et on terminera plutôt par les
ministres parce que là on aura des
questions précises à leur poser et non
pas des questions trop générales moi je
veux pas rester dans des généralités je
veux rentrer dans le détail vous pensez
remettre votre rapport quand ben on est
obligé de le remettre dans les 6 mois
donc c'est avant le 17 juillet donc sera
avantu avant peut-être un petit peu
avant parce que le mois de juillet va
être très occupé par les Jeux Olympiques
et donc on a intérêt nous à essayer de
sortir quelque chose fin fin juin si
possible avec une proposition de loi la
clé ça pourrait déboucher sur un texte
législatif ça peut ça peut c'est pas
obligatoire mais ça ça peut
effectivement servir de base des
propositions de loi merci Quentin tout à
l'heure merci Orian merci Vincent de oui
je reviens dans le club on parlera de ce
concept de réarmement notamment
démographique voilà présenté par le chef
de l'État cette semaine ce sera à suivre
dans le club merci Quentin et financé
par qui ah voilà on touj pas la réponse
non on peut poser cette question sur
beaucoup de
chos je la pose souvent moi un mot
puisque on parle des questions de prix
de pouvoir d'achat pour les Français sur
les autoroutes parce que c'est un sujet
sur lequel vous avez beaucoup travaillé
Bruno Lemer qui avait annoncé il y a
quelques mois une augmentation de moins
de 3 % en 2024 euh elle devrait être
annoncée dans les prochains jours cette
augmentation on est toujours sur cette
fourchette écoutez quand on dit moins de
3 % c'est qu'on est pas loin des 3 %
donc pour moi on va sans doute nous
annoncer que c'est 28 ou 29 hein moi je
m'attends à cela moi je trouve que c'est
pas justifié je trouvais déjà l'an
dernier on a augmenté de 475 % alors
bien sûr on va me dire c'est les
contrats les contrats sont mal fichus
c'est c'est c'est le gros problème de
ces concessions tourroutières c'est pas
la concession en elle-même c'est les
contrats de base et les contrats il
prévoient que l'augmentation des tarifs
chaque année dépende de l'inflation et
de 70 % de l'inflation donc quand quand
on a une forte inflation comme on a eu
l'an dernier comme on va encore avoir en
partie cette année on a une augmentation
qui est assez forte alors que les coûts
des sociétés d'autoroute les les coûts
de fonctionnement des sociétés
d'autoroute ne sont pas forcément liés à
l'inflation et n'augmentent pas dans les
mêmes proportions ce qui veut dire que
quand vous augmentez leur chiffre
d'affaires à travers l'augmentation des
tarifs des péages vous augmentez leurs
profit et et ils ont déjà des profits
qui sont nettement supérieurs à ce
qu'ils étaient attendus à l'origine et
c'est moi c'est ce que je réclame de la
part du gouvernement c'est qu'il tape du
poid sur la table et qu'à un moment
donné on puisse faire un point complet
sur cette situation qui n'est pas
intéressante pour l'intérêt général et
pour l'ensemble des Français on va voir
l'actualité dans nos région pour
terminero pas on va à Vichi aujourd'hui
dans l'Allier où on retrouve Mathieu
Pino bonjour Mathieu merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous responsable de l'agence
de Vich à la rédaction du journal La
Montagne Mathieu elle a on va parler
aujourd'hui dans vos pages de votre
dossier sur les difficultés des communes
à trouver une assurance vous êtes allé
rencontrer plusieurs élus sur ce sujet
oui exactement on parle souvent de la
hausse des coûts de l'énergie de la
baisse des dotations de l'État mais les
collectivités locales ont d'autres
soucis qui se voient moins des gros
soucis d'assurance pour faire cours soit
elles sont lâchées par leur compagnie
soit elles doivent payer des tarifs
exorbitants quelques exemples le premier
Arcueil une ville de 22000 habitants du
valde Marne en juin la France on s'en
souvient a connu des émeutes cette
commune n'est pas épargnée il y a de la
casse sur la voirie la facture avoisine
les 30000 € on est en juin le maire
envoie la facture à son assurance comme
d'habitude et part en vacances à son
retour mauvaise nouvelle il reçoit un
avenant à son contrat qui lui annonce
que sa franchise va passer de 1500 à 2
million d'euros en cas d'émeutes autre
exemple dans lae dans la commune du
cotau dans la lo le maire n'a plus
d'assurance depuis le 1er janvier en
fait la commune a subi un violent orage
de grêle en juin 2022 avec plus de 3
millions d'euros de dégâts et sa
compagnie a préféré résilier son contrat
et puis je pourrais vous parler aussi de
Dinan qui a dû prendre un assureur au
Japon parce que personne ne répondait
plus à son appel d'offre bref les
collectivités s'inquiètent plus d'un
milliers de Commines sont concernées
sont déjà concerné et c'est une source
supplémentaire de démotivation pour les
maires quelles sont les solutions
Mathieu pour ces communes vers qui elles
peuvent se tourner alors oui
heureusement il y a il y a quelques
pistes de travail pour avancer sur ce
sujet parce que les assureurs sont
parfois eux-mêmes en difficulté l'une de
ces pistes c'est la hiérarchisation des
sinistres ça veut dire quoi par exemple
que les communes pourraient arrêter de
déclarer leur petit sinistr comme le
rétroviseur cassé de la voiture de
l'agent communal les communes pourraient
donc s'auto-assurer et et installer ses
dépenses dans leur budget dans un
deuxième niveau les assureurs
continueraient de de porter les risques
des collectivités en cas de sinistre
sérieux comme un incendie d'école par
exemple et puis au troisème niveau ce
serait à l'état de prendre en charge les
sinistres exceptionnels en cas d'émeutes
ou d'aléas climatique c'est donc un
dossier brûlant d'autant que le climat
se dérègle de plus en plus et que la
société française est inflammable d'où
ma question monsieur le sénateur comment
avancer vite sur ces questions pour
éviter qu'une émeute ou qu'un orage vide
les caisses d'une commune et pour éviter
de finir de démotiver les élus locaux
oui alors c'est c'est un sujet que je
connais bien puisque j'étais maire 22
ans ça fait 7 ans que je ne suis plus
maire parce que elle cumule des mandats
on nous a empêché de de pouvoir être
parlementaire et maire ce que je trouve
dommage et euh ces histoires d'assurance
c'est pas nouveau parce Queen 2005 il y
a eu aussi des émeutes hein on en pas on
a peut-être un peu oublié mais euh à
Massie j'ai eu un gymnase qui a brûlé et
euh à l'époque bon on était assuré ça a
été remboursé mais ensuite les
compagnies d'assurance effectivement
nous ont fait monter les primes de façon
assez conséquente et les franchises
aussi et donc j'ai fait mes calculs j'ai
j'ai regardé un petit peu tout ça et
pendant plusieurs années on a été notre
propre assureur donc on s'est
auto-assuré et on a gagné de l'argent
donc je pense que c'est quelque chose
qu'il faut regarder à chaque fois
systématiquement et à la commission des
finances dont je fais partie au Sénat on
a décidé d'cidé de de réfléchir à la
question pour faire des propositions
dans dans le semestre qui vient donc
avant l'été on fera des propositions
pour essayer d'obtenir des compagnies
d'assurance quand même des engagements
plus plus clairs vis-à-vis des
collectivités et avec des des choses qui
soient acceptables pour tout le monde
effectivement pour pour certaines
communes c'est vrai qu'une grosse
commune peut absorber un peu plus
facilement le un incendie sur un gymnase
une petite commune sur une école qui
brûle si a trois écoles c'est c'est
c'est quand même super compliqué c'est
c'est encore plus compliqué donc c'est
une question qui effectivement concerne
les collectivités territoriales le Sénat
et la chambre des territoire donc en
tout cas on a pris conscience de ce
sujet là et on va le traiter
Mathieu une autre question vous avez
votre réponse c'est je crois que j'ai eu
mal c'est parfait ma on regarde votre
une alors l'All en chantier c'est à la
une de la montagne dans son édition de
Vichy la qui poursuit samue en 2024 et
on peut découvrir dans votre journal les
principaux chantiers qui seront menés
dans l'année à venir merci beaucoup
Mathieu Pino merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci lancent de la d'avoté
a